Ricky Williams takes the high road
that's a Sports Illustrated Films
production you can read the full story
on si.com slash Ricky poster boy for the
NFL's battle against marijuana Ricky
Williams takes the high road it's an
in-depth look at Ricky's life five years
after the end of his NFL career
Ricky joining us from the Bahamas and
former Texas Heisman Trophy winner Miami
Dolphin great rush for ten thousand
yards all right are you staying in shape
I used to how good shape are you end
down there well I am I'm uh I'm down
here doing a dolphin assisted therapy
program taking care taking care of my
body and what's that consist of so we
start in the morning and we're on tables
in each of us each there's 12 people
here absolute therapist to work with us
and then in the afternoon we we hop on a
boat and go to a dolphin facility and we
get in the water with the dolphins and
continue to therapy and it's dolphins
will come up and uh and actually
participate in in assists and so it's
really it's really quite amazing what
you do for you so the the therapy what
it does is it starts to remove layers of
trauma off the body and let the dolphin
do is they come in and assist and you
know they they communicate through sonar
and that's the same technology that
athletic trainers would use and so it's
just a it's an energy that goes through
tissue and clears uh clears block of
blockages and trauma out of the body how
much pain do you still have from your
football days huh you know I haven't had
much pain I I stay active I play
softball I play flag football but I had
a bad neck injury my last year in Miami
and so I'm starting to feel a little bit
of tingling and numbness down my left
arm when you hear athletes talk about in
particular football players that you
know they want to get rid of the the
pain pills and that marijuana medicinal
marijuana is is the route to go
how far away or how close are we do you
think that are we that the NFL would
adopt something like that you know I
think we're pretty far I think it sounds
probably gonna kind of wait until
there's more research done and I think
that's that's prudent on their part but
I also don't think it's that simple I
think with marijuana at least the way I
used it it wasn't strictly for pain it
was to just take care of myself
and so I I'd use after I got home from
practice just let go of the stress of
the day you know get on my yoga mat and
do some stretches and just stay in
contact with my body but as far as you
know because anything you take to numb
yourself and not to me is not in the
long run it's not a it's not a good idea
but anything you take to help yourself
take care of yourself is the way to go
what do you think marijuana is
beneficial then for pain I think it
definitely can be if it's used
consciously for sure well what does that
mean well so I think you know and so the
fact that it's been illegal it's been
something that's been underground and so
people know people use it and the
stereotype is they use it to get high
and sit on the couch watch television
and I think if if you're really okay
like I had an ankle injury and I would
come home and I'd smoke and I'd sit
there and I'd work on my I'd work on my
ankle and I you know after smoking it
was more sensitive to energy going on
down there and I could manipulate it and
get some good work done but I think if
you're just smoking to zone out and
forget about your worries that's just
going to create more pain down the road
what do you think the percentage was of
players that you played with who smoked
well I think it's from what I found I
played on three different teams and I
found that at various they varied them
on each team I think each team as a
culture so I'd say some teams it's
probably as low as 15% and some teams
that might be as high as 40 to 50
percent talking to Ricky Williams former
NFL all-pro running back iseman Trophy
winner joining us Dan Patrick show what
would you say to Commissioner Goodell if
he asked you about marijuana use good
bad
ugly quad say you know if you look at
all the issues that that NFL is dealing
with with concussions and players
suffering after after football and you
want to look at what you could do I
think you should give players you know
all reasonable means to take care of
themselves while they're playing and not
wouldn't suggest that you necessarily
suggest to doctors that that they
prescribed it but take it off the banned
list and have a program where players
are getting in trouble then you drug
test them and if you find that there's
drugs involved and then get them some
help but don't punish players who were
doing well on the field doing well
support uh representing the NFL but
failed a drug test you I know you failed
a drug test but you took a lot of drug
tests in your career how did you somehow
elude the long arm of the law sometimes
I eluded by not by not using and
sometimes I eluded by it's just just
tapering you know I realized that you
could take three puffs of a joint and
pass the test the next day I was
moderation being intelligent about it
did you but did you ever change urine
samples or because I know drug testing
is different now we're the Olympics
they're watching you take your urine
test did you have that no that was
probably the most stringent drug testing
program in the world
so I mean did they you walk in the guy
walks into the bathroom he says pants to
your knees and he watches you he watches
you pee what are you searching for these
days mm-hmm
the answer to life the key to life and
searching for truth and it's an eternal
search now I think it's true there's
something that's always evolving what
you know once you learn something you
realize that there's more beyond that
what would you tell the 20 year old
Ricky Williams now I would tell them you
know when you're done when you're done
with college I know you want you know I
know there's all this pressure and you
want to go to the NFL and make a lot of
money but take a year off get to know
yourself you know if I was not going
anywhere
and really get to know yourself before
you before you jump into
Singh how often do you get high now well
obviously I don't necessarily use that
terminology but I use cannabis it
depends I mean sometimes I'll go weeks
without and sometimes I'll I'll use
every day it just depends what's what's
going on if I feel it's gonna kind of
help and you did a Sports Illustrated
film it's Ricky Williams takes the high
road you can also read the story on
si.com slash Ricky what is the message
in this Sports Illustrated film that
you're that you want out well it's a
message that I want out and wherever I
when I walk down the street is that life
is better when you when you have the
courage to be yourself you know I just
see it I just tracked my life and I said
whenever I've tried to fit in and do
what's quote-unquote right never worked
whenever I decided to have the courage
to be myself things always worked out
better than I could have imagined
where's your Heisman my eyes minutes at
the in the office at the house how often
do you look at it what do you think when
you look at it well you know it's it's
in Austin inside and I spend so much
time around the football office it's
just a prep it represents what I what I
accomplished when I was in college and
and I think what I'm going through tough
times I I look at it and I realized that
inside of me I have I have a champion
and uh it motivates me to keep on going
or whatever I'm doing to reach the cop
would you let your kids play football
yeah my son plays football he goes to it
goes to a small private school so I'm
not I'm not too worried yeah he's he's
not as passionate about it as good as I
am so I'm convinced that once you've
done with with high school he's not
gonna have any desire to play anymore
and I'm good with that
I think football you know at to a
certain level teachers teachers may
encourage teachers teamwork teachers
accountability teachers a lot of
positive positive traits and as long as
you don't go too far and start banging
your head around too much I think it's
actually good for young boys you fear
that he could actually get good as a dad
and anyway don't in you to play no you
know when I was a kid I you know I loved
I love to play but there's you know I
wasn't such a difficult up
and there was this hunger and this need
to get rid of stress and anger so it was
a great channel but you know this kids
got a got a pretty good life and you
know I think you have to have a bit of
an edge or something to prove to go down
that road when did you lose that chip on
your shoulder that anger I still have it
it's just it's just redirected towards
towards moving forward not not towards
dealing with the past are you the first
draft pick and flag football I am and
I'm not sure if it's because of my my my
history of being Heisman Trophy winner
if it's because it's just cool to have
Ricky Williams on your team
it's great to talk to you Ricky yeah you
know maybe maybe we'll bring the show
down there you know it's that okay we'll
just kind of hang out come on well you
go for the Miami Dolphins to the real
dolphins yeah I figured I represented
the Dolphins well now it's their turn to
take care of me Ricky thank you we
appreciate it good luck Thank You Ricky
Williams takes the high road you can
read the whole story on si.com slash
Ricky he's interesting dude the fact
that he's with the dolphins and their
sonar helps that's what trainers use
he's he's interesting never never dull
moment with him the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience